[Music]
foreign
hello and welcome to the take with
Sophie Ridge live at nine here in the
heart of Westminster
now I want to do a slightly different
diff program today because it feels to
me that for a long time Westminster has
been dominated by personality Politics
the roller coaster of who's up and who's
down the Boris show can Liz truss
Outlast a lettuce
today well it feels pretty serious
inflation was expected to come down and
it didn't interest rates nailed on to
rise tomorrow what is going on with the
economy and just how painful is it going
to get we'll try and find out as we
bring you takes from all sides over the
next 60 minutes
we need to squeeze every last drop of
high inflation out of the economy
well it's bad news for everyone with a
mortgage but there's also bad news for
the chancellor there because it means
much higher costs for the government's
debt and that is now bigger than the
economy and it is of course also bad
news for this man who was on the
defensive earlier
what do we hear from one more gentlemen
he wants to borrow an extra 28 billion
pounds a year that would make the
situation worse
and the labor leader of course took
every opportunity to try and make the
Prime Minister feel uncomfortable
whilst his government is consumed in law
breaking Chaos on division working
people are paying the price
we talk of interest rates heading
towards six percent we're going to try
and have a grown-up conversation with
our guests on the show this evening in a
while we're going to hear from the
transport secretary Mark Harper
the labor MP and member of the treasury
select committee restaurant at Ali will
be on the program plus we're going to be
talking to the economist Jared Lyons and
much more besides on the take
[Music]
hello and good evening well it certainly
is all eyes on the economy this evening
the bank of England almost guaranteed to
raise rates by at least a quarter point
maybe even a half point and those rates
are likely to stay higher for longer
because inflation is remaining
stubbornly High there's been lots more
going on too so let's crack straight on
and start with the best bits of the week
so far
three and a half years ago Boris Johnson
led the conservative party to election
Victory but tonight MPS voted to remove
his pass for the House of Commons are
you gonna miss Boris Johnson Richie
sunac or is it good riddance this
matters because the Integrity of our
institutions matter they go from the
vindictive to the ridiculous with not
allowing him a parliamentary pass I was
assured that I should continue the work
that the house had mandated with the
appointment that the house had put me
into and so I did just that
[Applause]
the eyes to the right
354 the nose to the left seven it's
level but level at a really troubling
number 8.7 percent the expectations
where this number will be starting to
fall we won't be pushed off course
because if we're going to help families
if we're going to relieve the pressure
on people with mortgages on businesses
we need to squeeze every last drop of
high inflation out of the economy mines
here in London are really focused on not
just winning the fighting on the ground
but winning the peace afterwards we are
sending a message
that our support on the battlefield and
Beyond cannot be outlasted
we built Ukraine will build freedom
country region continent World premise
has a keen interest in the mortgage
Market in California but I'm talking
about what we told us here and whilst
his government is consumed in law
breaking chaos and division working
people are paying a price what do we
hear from one more gentleman he wants to
borrow an extra 28 billion pounds
[Music]
from the North Sea that would make the
situation worse
well it feels like there's been an awful
lot of fed Boris Johnson in the news
recently as that shows but I really do
want to concentrate on the economy uh
this evening let's start with the
government shall we because a few
moments ago I spoke to the transport
secretary Mark Harper
we were expecting inflation to fall but
it's now stayed at 8.7 are you still
confident that you're going to meet your
target to have inflation by the end of
the year I think the forecast that that
there are out there from the various
forecasts and still say that inflation
is going to fall to that level by the
end of the year clearly it's taking a
bit longer but what that actually says
to me is that we've got to remain
focused on halving inflation and
actually what the government's got to do
the bank of England has the primary
responsibility for reducing inflation
with with its monetary policy what the
government's got to do for the decisions
we take to make sure we help the bank of
England achieve that objective we won't
help anybody if we take steps that cause
inflation to rise so that's why we've
had some what kind of steps would cause
inflation to rise well it's why for
example we've had to make very difficult
decisions which you and I have discussed
before on your your programs about
public sector pay for example it's why
the government has had to make fair and
reasonable offers to people but but have
had to make ones lower than inflation
because if we'd made inflation busting
pay Rises that would have the
forecasters have suggested that would
make things worse we've got to make sure
we keep the public finances under
control so that means making
decisions about how you prioritize
spending so I think if the government
does what it it has control of and works
with the bank of England that's how you
give the banking the ability to drive
down inflation and meet the government's
objectives of halving it by the end of
the year are you really keeping
government spending down borrowing down
I thought debt was now 100 of GDP well
we're controlling public spending
we've made a lot of difficult decisions
you know I set out some borrowings again
last month I may set out some difficult
choices in in my area of Transport
budgets earlier this year that's why
we're making I've been on your program a
lot talking about the tough choices
we've had to make on public sector pay
so I think the government is making
those decisions but it's necessary to
get inflation under control that's
actually the most important thing we can
do if we let if we don't do those things
we slow down the fall in inflation and
that doesn't help anybody and interest
rates I guess it's inevitable they're
going to go up right well I'm not going
to speculate on them that's you know
we've only got to wait until tomorrow
those are decisions for the bank of
England no one welcomes a rising
interest rates and I don't underestimate
how tough it is for people it's one of
the reasons why over the last year the
government's provided
three thousand three hundred pounds on
average of help for every family a lot
of that obviously is the help with
energy bills obviously as energy bills
come down that help won't be as
necessary so we don't underestimate the
difficulty for people we're not
pretending this is easy but getting
inflation down is the thing that will
help people the most I guess
you know you talk about energy but Bill
said
a mortgages I think that's kind of the
point right you have this this huge
intervention to help people with their
energy bills when they when they were
going up
through no fault of any monies and
people having to swallow these huge
bills people on mortgage rates on
variable rates or common with their
fixed terms deals I think we can have a
quick look to sort of show how high
they're due to go and how painful that
could potentially be up to just the last
few days you can see going right back up
to the average interest about six
percent 5.72 percent
some people will be saying this is
disproportionately impacting a smaller
number of people why aren't you stepping
in specifically to help them well look I
think the chancellor was asked this
question specifically yesterday when he
was in the House of Commons and he made
the position very clear if you pump uh
more debt into the economy you actually
slow down the Fallen inflation and you
actually make things worse so the best
thing you can do is work with the bank
of England help them drive down
inflation the forecasts that are out
there from independent forecasters so
not not the government's forecast still
say that inflation will be significantly
reduced by the end of the year that is
the best way we can help people
including homeowners who are facing
higher mortgage rates the government's
not pretending it's going to be easy for
anyone but unless you get that inflation
under control actually you're not
helping anyone at all now I just want to
talk about this in like really simple
sort of language right I'm not an
economist so I'm just trying to kind of
get to the bottom of what going on in
the simplest of ways to help people like
me who are trying to get their head
around all this right so we need
inflation to come down and the way we're
trying to do this is to make borrowing
more expensive and as you say to make
sure wages aren't going up too quickly
so in other words is the aim to make
people feel poorer so they stop spending
so much money
uh well it's it's to it's to slow down
the economy by stopping people a little
bit right to reduce spending
um and then that helps Bear Down on
inflation and then on keeping so that is
kind of that that is correct then
keeping discipline on public sector pay
which is the thing the government
control is partly for the direct effect
of controlling public sector pay but
also to make sure that you then don't
um drive up pay elsewhere in the economy
because keeping pay under control is
important and that's difficult as well
you know people you've had this
conversation about New York if you do
inflation busting pay Rises it it
doesn't help so I'm just going back to
well I'm trying to work out right so in
a way it's going to be painful but
that's kind of the point
I said look no one thinks this is is
easy for people but if you if you don't
get inflation under control the worst
thing is not getting inflation under
control as the chance alert made clear
so I think have to stick with which is
called Square on uh you know we have
seen it come down but it's not coming
down as fast as we would like so we've
got to stick with it uh that's the best
tax cut you can deliver people is to get
inflation under control but I think
we're pretending it's going to be
straightforward let's have a look at the
international comparison here because we
had months of people saying look the
target is to get inflation down that's
what this government's all about it's
you've made it one of your private
pedgers you've said judges on this right
and if you compare the inflation rates
in the UK the US and the Eurozone I just
want to have a look here UK inflation
8.7 the US four percent Eurozone 6.1
percent
I mean it looks a bit like a UK problem
well no if you if you listen to the ons
when they were setting out the inflation
figures I listened to them carefully one
of the points they made you've got to be
careful with the comparisons
internationally because of the way we've
chosen to support people with Energy
prices and that actually does make a
difference in the international so
that's the problems it does make a
difference in the international
comparisons the ons said that themselves
look inflation's been high uh globally
interest rates are going out come on
around it except I'm not trying to I'm
not trying to have a go in this
interview I'm trying to get to the
bottom and stuff right I'm trying to
have a grown-up conversation about the
interest rates if there is a UK specific
problem is it not better to say this is
why this is what we're going to do about
it
there's a problem in order to fix it
interest rates have been high anywhere
we'd be very clear that inflation is in
sticky in terms of coming down part of
the reason you know when we were having
these all the conversations we've had
this year about why a public sector in
the UK
because one of the reasons we made the
point about public sector pay was to
make sure we get pay under control
because one of the things we were
concerned about was not doing that
why is it sticky in the UK why is that
well if you listen Theory list there's
lots of factors that drive inflation
some of it's International and we we're
suffering from some of those as well
Energy prices
some of it's on the effect that pay has
in the economy one of the other things
is you'll know post pandemic we saw a
lot of people leave the labor market
which means you've got a very tight
labor market which pushes up pay one of
the things the government is doing
things that we can control through the
department of work and pensions is
looking at helping people who fell out
of the labor market to get back into the
labor market which helps then so it's
high wage pay under control you
you think it is higher wages well that's
part of the problem if you look at the
things that are driving at prices that's
why people take a paper that's why no
that's not what the government's saying
we're saying we want to get more people
into the labor market that's what we're
doing through job centers looking at
skills getting more people into the
labor market and that's how you enable
the economy to continue growing but
keeping pay under control
um do you have confidence in the
government of the bank of England
yes the government look the governor of
the Bank of India has a difficult job to
do the job of the government and the
chancellor is to work with the governor
and the monetary policy committee to
support them to get inflation under
control they're doing an important job
uh it's a tough job
um they're independent for a reason uh
they have to make these tough decisions
um but the government's working very
closely and has confidence in the bank
yes why why do you have confidence in
the government the bank of England
uh because I think he is doing that he's
making the tough decisions with the
monetary policy committee that are
necessary it's never
popular to put up interest rates I think
the bank has a job they were too slow
right that's a criticism isn't it
some people make that criticism yes and
there was a decision to make at the
beginning about whether inflation was
transitored or not you may remember
Rishi sunak made it clear when he was
Chancellor that he thought inflation was
a problem actually he saw that early on
one of the reasons why one of the
reasons why I backed him to be prime
minister because I think he uh he knows
his stuff when it comes to economics
that's why he wants to support the bank
in driving down inflation because he
knows that it's only when we get
inflation under control that we'll be at
a then lower interest rates and get the
economy motoring and grow it okay uh
we'll have to see uh what happens but
certainly you know difficult as you
ignored yourself a difficult a few
months if not longer a few years
potentially ahead for the UK economy
um I wanted to talk to you about Ukraine
uh if I may as well um you were
answering more support for Ukraine yes
so the prime minister so as you know
there's the Ukraine recovery conference
today and tomorrow which the government
is hosting with the government of
Ukraine which is taking place in London
and the Prime Minister this morning set
out further support for Ukraine in terms
of uh guarantees for loans also very
importantly
um an insurance framework a risk
framework to enable prior the private
sector to have confidence to invest and
president zielinski spoke virtually at
the conference this morning I spoke at
one of the sessions following the Deputy
Prime Minister of Ukraine
um for some of their reconstruction
efforts so the government remains
focused not just on helping with
supplying weapons and other support but
also helping with the reconstruction of
Ukraine and helping them keep their
economy going which I think is
incredibly important okay
okay thank you
meant to be there with the transport
secretary Mark Harper and a bit later
we're going to have a closer look at the
state of the economy and tomorrow's
expected interest rate rise what it can
mean for people in the coming months
ahead but first though let's get a bit
of immediate reaction to that interview
we can talk to Sam one of the things
that jumped out to me was when he was
talking about the government the bank of
England
um very careful not to directly
criticize him
but he did kind of make the point that
oh maybe he misjudged inflation a little
bit at the beginning what did you think
oh definitely one maybe two raised
eyebrows at what Mark Harper just said
to you because the transports actually
actually went there he went there with
the criticism that you're hearing in
private from loads of conservative MPS
over in the house of parliament now back
in 2021 Andrew Bailey who was at that
point pretty new to the job of
government of the bank of England said
that he thought that inflation was
transitory it's pretty temporary and it
basically he was making an argument not
to overreact to her see how that's gone
now now what Mark Harper did it's
something that we saw quite a lot of
when Liz trust was prime minister which
is criticism by government Ministers of
the bank of England and he said actually
Andrew belly got it wrong Richard soon I
got it right that's one of the reasons
why I backed Rishi seen that to be prime
minister but that is criticism and
that's criticism by a cabinet minister
of the bank of England's Governor that
didn't end well last time it didn't but
you can also see see can't you sound the
frustration that perhaps some people are
feeling that the bank isn't tackling it
in the way that it needs to do I want to
just get to a kind of wider point that I
was trying to get to in that interview
which is I want to kind of strip away
all the sort of serious long words and
which I think sometimes to be frank with
you
um politicians use so they don't have to
completely face up and be truthful about
what is happening which is that they
want people to feel economic pain in
order to bring inflation down not
because they're you know bad people but
because they think that is the best way
of getting to the economic place they
need to right that's right and this goes
to the heart of why I think they're so
worried in number 10 and in the TR and
in the treasury because we saw this
morning inflation uh figures of 8.7 same
as last month but critically core
inflation uh going up it's going down in
America it's going down in the Years you
can see the overall uh inflation figures
here but the way that you deal with
inflation traditionally is to put up
interest rates put up everybody's
borrowing costs because then the theory
goes that people can't afford to spend
as much and then that economy cools down
prices come down uh and you see uh you
see the you know you see the interest
rates going up here but um those
interest rates going up I'm into stops
people people spending to curb their
spending habits but the big nightmare
for this government is that that's not
happening the rates are going up they're
pulling the lever in the Bank of England
but spending isn't slowing because
people are churning through savings that
they built up during uh the pandemic you
know this primarily affects people with
variable rate mortgages that's not a
huge number of people or people who come
off fixed rate mortgages and whilst
we're talking low millions of people
there are still you know 30 40 million
households so there are lots of people
who don't suddenly feel a big squeeze in
their income from these interest rate
Rises sure there's pressure all over the
place but it's not having the effect
that it should and ministers are sitting
around going well if you pull a lever
and nothing happens we're not sure what
to do but the most likely outcome is the
bad convenience keeps putting up rates
yet further and maybe there is something
of a bigger kind of slump a bigger
problem a bigger moment later on where
people suddenly really find that they
can't afford things that's generally uh
genuinely quite worrying um Sam thank
you very much indeed for your analysis
as always Sam's take what happened more
from Sam later on the program including
it's pretty cool new polling tool that
we've got to show you anyway we're live
here in Westminster up next we'll be
taking a closer look at today's premises
questions
foreign
[Music]
ER and I'm Sky's U.S correspondent based
here in Los Angeles it's turning
everybody into a crazy violent drug
addict
how are you feeling I am angry
I quit sir will your candidates win I
hope so I gotta be realistic my sister's
dead
more than four weeks on there's no
murder weapon and no suspect
mum how are you feeling today Jeffrey
said you answered again you just don't
cross her I'm so excited
severe nightmares of these people coming
in and just taking me in the middle of
the night
I've watched as whole towns were torn
apart by natural disaster I'm alive and
I'm thankful for that we take you to the
heart of the stories which shape our
world
a lot of cases that I know are reported
from Ukrainian missiles themselves
Ambassador with respect
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
hello welcome back live to Westminster
you're watching the take now wish you
see next day started by introducing the
Ukrainian presidents at a conference in
London but the Prime Minister faced a
more hostile audience at lunchtime in
the Commons pmqs was dominated by
exchanges with the labor leader on the
UK's worryingly stubborn inflation this
costama attached the PM over what he
called the Tory mortgage penalty facing
families here is pmqs unwrapped with
that political correspondent to Jay Pike
this morning's shock inflation figures
meant kierstama only had one option
asking about the economy and he went big
on the blame game he knows very well the
cause of the mortgage catastrophe 13
years of economic failure and atori
kamikazu budget which crashed the
economy and put mortgages through the
roof the labor leader also seemed to
have a new three-word attack line
Willa promised to tell us how much the
Tory mortgage penalty Tory mortgage
penalty the Tory mortgage penalty is
going to cost the average homeowner I'm
told you'll hear a lot more of that in
the next 12 months zakiya also snuck in
a mention of Selby in Yorkshire location
of a key by-election next month and in
response really soon act strategy was to
argue economic challenges are evidence
internationally
perhaps the old gentleman could explain
why interest rates are at similar levels
in the United States in Canada in
Australia and New Zealand but in
contrast what do we hear from one more
gentlemen he wants to borrow an extra 28
billion pounds a year that would make
the situation worse he wants to ban new
supplies of energy from the naughty that
would make the situation worse now Kia
stalma's advisors say it was a
deliberate choice to focus on the issue
concerning voters the cost of living
crisis and Rising mortgage rates and not
deal with the soap opera of Boris
Johnson and the Privileges committee but
the labor leader still managed to slip
in the odd dig Mr Speaker I realized the
promise to spend all week saying he
doesn't want to influence anyone or
anything
Market in California but I'm talking
about movie told us here I'm sure from
the vantage point of his helicopter
everything might look fine
but that's not the lived experience of
those on the ground all that seemed to
leave the Prime Minister looking a
little irritable
no amount of personal attacks and Petty
Point scoring can disguise the fact that
the honorable gentleman does not have a
plan for this country Mr Speaker Now
personal attacks and Petty Point scoring
may not be the point of pmqs but they're
always a regular feature and as Kia
Stalin didn't major on Boris Johnson the
smps Westminster leader as well as
laborback benchers filled that void
given the dire economic reality of
today's I'm not no clear that he's taken
his honesty lessons from Boris Johnson
does the Prime Minister believe that the
reward for being a law breaker should be
to be made a lawmaker so just to recap
during this Parliament we've had one
Tory prime minister who turned out to be
a proven liar a second Tory prime
minister who was outlasted by a lettuce
after this week's pathetic no-show by
the Prime Minister what one word would
he use to describe himself might it be
weak what's weak is the party opposite
being unable to stand up is being able
to unable to stand up to the people who
fund them and stand behind hard-working
families in this country
wish you two next time as Chancellor
during the pandemic and his supposed
Mastery of economic issues was and
remains a key selling point of his
leadership and he doesn't seem to enjoy
all of that now being a target for
opposition parties whatever the truth of
the causes of both the cost of living
crisis and the mortgage rates increase
labor is unlikely to let up with its
attacks and as homeowners increasingly
fill the bite that may prove painful for
the PM
at jpike there it feels like it may
indeed prove painful for the PM likely
to dominate all the way up to the next
general election campaign we are live in
Westminster for you you're watching the
take up next we're only taking an even
closer look at the issue that we are
discussing in detail today the state of
the economy and how stubborn inflation
could influence the next general
election
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
hello welcome back live to Westminster
you're watching the take now all through
the program we've been talking about
that incredibly stubborn inflation worse
than in other places like the US and the
Eurozone which means the bank of England
is almost certain to raise interest
rates tomorrow with potentially many
more Rises to come business and
economics correspondent can explain
inflation really is the problem that
won't quite go away and you can see how
sticky it is here the blue line where
over the hump but it's not falling
anywhere near as fast as policy makers
would like it stayed flat at 8.7 last
month that's considerably higher than
the bank's two percent Target and look
at this before the lockdown it's also a
lot higher than the type of inflation
we're used to in the UK so we've got
some way to go to get it back down and
when we're thinking about what's driving
this persistent inflation well you can
see that food and drink is easing off
right the bottom there that red line but
prices here are still rising at an
annual rate of 18 so don't be fooled by
that red bar meanwhile at the top in the
blue it's Leisure Pursuits like eating
out Recreation and culture that are now
driving inflation
so even though prices are rising people
are still finding money to spend and
it's possibly why the bank of England is
worried about robust pay Rises that
workers in Britain have been securing
and this type of spending is becoming
increasingly a problem we will often
hear that inflation is a global problem
caused in part by factors out of our
control like the energy crisis but if we
strip away volatile items like food and
energy out of their headline rate we can
see that underlying pressures so that's
the red line or core inflation in the UK
is rising
that's something our counterparts in
Europe and the US are not grappling with
and all of this it's uncomfortable for a
government that's trying to figure out
how it may tempt voters next year ahead
of a general election government debt as
you can see here is a proportion of GDP
is at its highest since the 1960s and
soaring interest rates makes servicing
that debt all the more painful
so it's a tough State of Affairs for a
country grappling with the cost of
living crisis and a government that's
been talking tough on inflation but not
yet delivering the desired results
I go up right there talking is through
some of those all-important charts now
back to the politics because kirstana
was making a lot of latest new free
phrase uh the Tory mortgage penalty I
feel like we're going to hear this quite
a lot at pmqs today so let's get the
view from labor now we joined in the
studio with rosharana Ali who also
speaks on the treasury select committee
as well thanks very much for being on
the program hi how much of a shock was
it today when inflation just didn't fall
it was a huge shock but in some ways
it's not uh surprising because what
we've seen is that the UK has got some
additional Dimensions to the crisis we
Face first of all other countries didn't
have the Liz truss mini budget Fiasco
which has had a direct impact on
people's mortgages it has led to a
follow-on budget where the new
Chancellor had has had to introduce a
consolidation package so that's quite
different from other countries and also
we entered into the pandemic with the
uncertainties around brexit with a trade
agreement that did leave outstanding
issues around supply chain disruptions
you know inflation food related food
price inflation is higher for us in
terms of what we import from the
European Union so there are some factors
that makes it harder for the UK but I
think uh the that overall I would say
that when you come compare the UK to
other countries on mortgages the UK is
worse off than France than Germany and
that I'm afraid is down to economic
mismanagement underpinned by political
instability that we've had in this
country for the last few years but
particularly the last year which has
consequences on the economy it's
obviously the easiest thing for labor
politically to blame the conceptors for
for this I'm not saying that that's not
there's no Factor at this time I mean
but I just wonder if there's also
something you could say about the way
that bank of England has handled it
right because there's people who say
that they were too slow to react to what
happened and so having to overcompensate
and also that they did pump an awful lot
of money into the economy through
quantitative easing and stuff as well
which has an inflationary I mean I'll
come on to that if you can't say if you
can't if labor if you think labor
shouldn't call I'm not saying that at
all I'm not saying that and I also
allowed you too I I I'm absolutely not
so mad and also allowed you to make your
points but I'm just saying that okay the
difficult question
I guess is do you think this is partly
because of the bank of England as well
well I think that there is a there is a
certainly an issue about the point at
which quantitative easing should have
been phased out uh and some of us uh I
certainly raise those issues about
whether inflation was going to be
transitory which is what the governor of
the bank of England thought at the time
would happen his argument is that they
didn't see Ukraine coming they didn't
see the energy crisis coming but we and
you know we are much more vulnerable as
an economy because of the brexit
uncertainties and other factors that are
quite unique to the UK so yes one could
argue that uh with the benefit of
hindsight it would have been much better
for the bank of England to take action
earlier and phase in interest rates
gradually but we did have a major
pandemic uh I think the the other issue
though is that last year and it's not a
political point last year again we read
I raised these issues at the treasury
committee before for the Liz trust
budget came it was very clear that if
she won she was going to go in the
opposite direction to the governor of
the bank of England in terms of trying
to bring inflation uh keep inflation
under control
and yet Liz truss was proposing a big
budget spend that was not it wasn't
clear how it was going to be funded and
we were arguing that these this
Divergence was very dangerous and there
wasn't enough called policy coordination
what we're seeing again is the current
government isn't actually being
coordinated enough with the bank of
England in terms of providing support to
mortgage mortgage holders they could do
they could be much more uh assertive in
working with the bank as well as well
it's not it's not optimizing
Independence and certainly with The
Regulators I'm just asking on the
because my understanding I'm I'm no
expert is if you trying to help people
with their mortgages then that is going
to be I mean that's kind of negates the
point right well you can do certain
things what you can do is make sure
first of all uh the government uh has
done very little
um and The Regulators haven't done
enough to make sure that Savers have the
uh the interest rates that the increase
in interest is passed on to Savers
that's about 23 billion a year if we're
serious about taking money out of the
economy uh and uh bringing inflation
down then the government needs the bank
of England and the financial uh conduct
Authority needs to be more assertive in
ensuring that Banks pass on those saving
rates to Savers would you like would how
would you see that happen well I think
there's a role for the regulator to do
that if and also in terms of what the
government sets out and and
um encourages the the banks to do I know
that the Chancellor's meeting the key
some of the major Banks later this week
he needs to make it very clear that we
expect to see along with the governor of
the bank of England and the head of the
FCA we expect more interest rates to be
passed on to Savers because that would
help in terms of reducing the money
supply in the economy the second thing
is that the the the the FCA could do
more in terms of making sure that they
provide guidance to Banks about uh
spreading out mortgages over a longer
period of time now we need to be careful
that that doesn't then mean the actual
cost of borrowing in the long term is
born yet again by the the mortgage
holders but if we want to take mortgage
if we want to prevent uh repossessions
then we do need to look at ways in which
the regulator can direct Banks to be
sensitive to repossessions and make sure
that they put in place plans to support
them if you look at the amount of
profits the banks have made recently uh
it's pretty phenomenal so they could do
more to prevent the distress which would
be damaging for them as well if people
face repossession on a large scale
really interesting to talk thanks very
much for being on the program today Ali
there well if that was a view from labor
we can hear now from someone who's often
seen as an economist of the right Dr
Jared Alliance an economical use of
advise Boris Johnson he joins us now
live from Kent
how worried should we be about stubborn
inflation
yes we yes we should be very concerned
the reality is that the two key factors
that led to the initial surge of the
inflation were external Global factors
and very poor monetary policy by the
bank of England they completely misread
the situation and both of those factors
in some respects are now being reversed
the global factors have gone the bank of
England is catching up with where they
should have been the challenge now
coming directly to your question is the
second round effects firms are passing
on high costs either to maintain profit
margins or to increase profit margins
you've also focused on wages although it
should be stressed last year wages were
not the factor accounting for this
inflation
so the second round effects now Evelyn
that makes us more concerned as
economists and that's why we should all
be worried the reality though is it's
the bank of England who really should be
taking the blame here they completely
misread the situation a couple years ago
the markets now have no correct
confidence in the bank and the governor
and the NPC are seen as lacking
competence and lacking credibility and
the real challenge now is that the bank
of England even though they should be
pausing in some respects like the
Americans last week the U.S federal
reserve their Central Bank has
credibility they were able to say we're
going to take a pause with a bias to
raise rates again if necessary that
would be the position we should be in in
the UK If the bank of England had
probability but they don't so tomorrow
they're going to be forced to raise
rates probably quite sharply probably by
half a percent and they still will have
a bias to have to raise rates again to
try and get on top of the situation so
the worry should be not only about
inflation coming back to your question
but the fact that the bank of England is
now going to have to push rates up to
such a level is going to weaken the
economy and if they push rates up too
much force a recession
I mean that is pretty Grim to be honest
uh listening to you really interesting
to hear where you quite clearly put the
majority of the blame I guess my next
question is what do you think should
happen next are we doing the right thing
by increasing rates and having the
squeeze and the pain that that entails
or is there another path available
you will to answer that question I think
it's vital that people understand where
we work up years ago that time I was on
Sky saying the question is which p is it
will inflation pass through will it
persist or will it become permanent the
bank of England said it was going to
pass through quickly be transitory it
was quite clear then two years ago they
were wrong now we have inflation
persisting two years ago when inflation
hit 0.4 percent in February 2021 it was
clear it was going to pick up that only
two months later it went above the two
percent Target it was clear the economy
was about to rebound as it was being
unlocked therefore in that situation
interest rates should have been
increased what happened the bank of
England kept rates low they injected a
phenomenal amount of money into the
economy through quantitative easing and
all nine members of the MPC monetary
policy committee voted for it and I'm on
two boards in the city in early 2021 we
received letters from the bank of
England saying be prepared that your
systems can tolerate negative interest
rates so not only do they not act they
went in the wrong direction since then
their credibility has been hit by the
fact they've always been seen as too
late
the way they communicate is literally
terrible there's a parallel universe
between what is often said in the real
but in the political world and what's
actually said in the dealing rooms in
the city and now we have a situation
where the city Global markets are saying
look you need to show that you're on top
of this situation
and unfortunately the economy here is
vulnerable because monetary policy
tightening works with a long land 12 to
18 months so we've already gone from
interest rates of only 0.1 to 4.5
percent a large part of that has yet to
actually hit people and yet to hit
companies but now because of the lack of
credibility and because of the poor
inflation figures for the last few
months inflation expectations arising
the bank is going to have to push rates
higher what will I do well if I was
there we wouldn't be in this situation
because it was quite clear two years ago
what needed to be done but now we are
where we are you have to basically
restore credibility and confidence what
the bank has to do in monetary terms is
effectively what Jeremy Hunt had to do
in fiscal terms last Autumn he had to
try and restore some credibility by
taking tap action the bank now has to do
that but when an economy already has
interest rates at the highest level for
some time and parts of the economy are
vulnerable High rates because they
they're over leveraged that means the
more you push rates up the more you're
going to add to problems in terms of the
real economy so if one looks at the
government's five measures three of
those are economic measures inflation
will fall albeit stubbornly stubborn at
the moment but will fall but the price
of it falling might impact two of those
other three economic measures the prime
minister is highlighting namely growth
and debt because if the economy is weak
and if interest rates are higher our
debt to picture government debt becomes
more vulnerable has to be said even
though the situation is difficult in the
UK it is a western world problem we've
been impacted a bit more by Energy
prices here in the UK but it's a problem
impacting Western Europe the states as
well as the UK but partly because of the
reasons I've just articulated I just
want to jump in if I make that I do want
to get to one other point are you
mentioning debt there and I think this
is another big part of the conversation
right you were saying that that the
government has restored some fiscal
credibility but I guess my question is
has it because you know today we saw
debt reaching 100 of uh GDP we're
talking about you know politicians
clamoring for tax cuts if they're on the
conservative side on the labor side
they're talking about big investment
do government really politicians of all
colors really get fiscal restraint that
perhaps is needed in order to keep
inflation though
yeah the international monetary fund a
few months ago came out with something
called their fiscal monitor six of the
seven G7 countries will likely be in a
debt trap over the next five years
according to the international monetary
fund that's where your debt is around
100 of GDP that is the size of your
economy and the rate of interest you're
paying on it is higher than your rate of
economic growth however it doesn't
really matter who's in pair at the
moment or who wins the next election
they inherit that very difficult
backdrop and the choices then need to be
made after that so the way out of a debt
trap is to basically get on top of
inflation that allows inflation to come
down it allows interest rates to
stabilize and then have a pro pro
economic strategy but that takes some
time but at the moment it's about
stabilizing the markets by getting on
top of inflation but coming back to your
question the best way out of a debt
problem is to keep your interest rates
low and get your rate of economic growth
up and to do that you need to actually
have more proactive policies to help
business and change reduce the cost of
living for consumers the good news in
the UK is the jobs Market is pretty good
so that's it's not all pessimistic the
job situation is the one real positive
out there at the moment
quite nice to have a bit of a positive
news I have to say I feel a bit guilty
today because I feel like we're just
having so much bad news in the program
but it does feel like it's one of those
days and when I was interviewing Mark
Harper earlier he made big points about
pay restraint he clearly believes and
this is obviously a viewing government
as well that pay Rises are driving
inflation are they right
look last year the search and inflation
had nothing to do with higher wages but
partly because we haven't as a country
largely because of the Central Bank the
bank of England not got on top of
inflation we're in that second round
phase and in the second round phase
wages and corporate behavior in terms of
profit margins is key so it's not just
workers it's also what companies do and
that's why the argument is it's a bit of
a
difficult argument those for the general
public to hear is that that's why people
say you have to tighten monetary policy
to slow the economy down but do bear in
mind as I was saying earlier monetary
policy works with a lag it's a long leg
what I hope is that the bank of England
doesn't overdo it by tightening too much
but coming back to your question higher
wages weren't the reason last year but
you can't blame people for seeking High
wages now because inflation is high but
as inflation starts to fall over next
year one would expect wage increases to
slow as well as approach to decelerate
really interesting to talk thanks very
much for giving your perspective
I should suggest
oh we certainly are hearing I guess some
people are starting to point the finger
a bit towards the bank of England we've
had lots of takes this evening I want to
take you back over to the screen area
where we can chat to you Sam because we
have something to show you tonight what
do we got Sam we've got a new toy uh
let's bring it up it's something that
we're going to talk about a lot on this
show uh in the evenings on Sky News now
you gov opinion uh Mori those are the
names of lots of posters you're going to
be hearing about all of them in the
run-up to a general election which one's
the most reliable well nobody will know
until the day after polling day when we
got the results
but and every poster uses a different
way of measuring public opinion to find
out whether labor or the conservatives
uh are going to be in number 10 how the
liberal Democrats are doing and all the
other parties so we have a new tool for
you at school and he's been launched
today at five o'clock very pleased to do
it on television for the first time it
is a poll of polls a polling tracker
what this does is it takes every single
poll and puts it in one place it gives
you an average so the danger when you
overlook because I don't think there's
any secret where Westminster obsessives
we tend to look at every poll and get
excited maybe even over excited from
never come on Sam so what we've done
what you need to do is take a little bit
of a sober look and sober step back and
look at how every pole fits with all the
others see if you can spot a trend
because it's Trends in polling that
really matter and so we've taken all the
polls and put them in one place and
given you an average and what this shows
it doesn't quite show you on the screen
uh but it this actually shows that the
labor party leads the conservatives now
when you look at every single poll by an
average of 18 percentage points that's a
pretty healthy lead uh for the
conservative party uh the liberal
Democrats are on 10 uh uh the greens uh
on six now um the thing that you've got
to realize about this is that polls have
a massive variety so labor could be as
high as 48 as low as falling at one
percent in the current range that's why
there's uncertainty that's why we need
to do this exercise looking at every
poll in the round um and the great thing
for people like me who do interviews
with politicians right is because if you
pull out a poll and you stick it in the
screen behind you and you say this is
really bad news for your party or you
must be really happy and a hoop
about this they invariably say well you
can't get over excited about one pole
it's only a poll well this isn't just a
poll right so actually this I guess is
our best evidence too it's our best way
of making sure that we don't get over
excited by one uh maybe kind of outlier
exactly because it's taking all of the
data now individual polls are still
interested the individual polls are the
only way to get deep into the data to
look at different demographics look at
how different bits of the population are
behaving how that's moving over time but
only by doing this and you can see the
trend this is where Rishi sunak became
prime minister immediately before you
see that great big spike for the labor
party you can see over the course of the
last six months or so some of the edge
being taken off the labor Advantage but
what you don't see back since November
is any sign really of a tory recovery
and if you look over here the lowest
Poll for the conservatives down at 26
but the highest is 29 that range is
quite quite small that suggests that you
know people aren't there isn't great
deal of me moving there's not great deal
of uncertainty in that poll much more on
the labor side but it's a big range um
gotta cut your sound do you get the
sense that Sam could talk about about
this all night for about you know three
hours because I certainly do and it
sounds fascinating I'm actually really
excited to see how this is a tool that
we can use between now and the election
as well thank you we have got a bit of
breaking news to bring you uh now
courtesy of our security and Defender
editor Deborah Haynes and that is about
the defense secretary Ben Wallace and
Nate well we can talk straight to uh
Deborah who is dialing in to bring us
the very latest Deborah
yes well it's actually a scoop in
economists they've spoken to Ben Wallace
and he's told them that he's basically
out of the running to be the next
Secretary General of NATO it's a pretty
secretive process but we all know that
Ben Wallace has been trying
um with the backing of the Prime
Minister to get that top job at NATO to
take over from Jen stoltenberg the
long-serving NATO Secretary General a
number of European countries had been
backing Ben Wallace he's really made a
mark with um the forward-leaning nature
that the UK has had with support for
Ukraine that gets in the backing of Joe
Biden in the United States is a key part
for any NATO Secretary General
perspective and it seems as though the
United States weren't going to put their
weight behind Ben Wallace's candidacy
and the defense secretary in this
interview with the economist and says
that the United States wants the current
incumbent to stay in post until next
year and lots of sources have said to
that said that to me too that the senses
that they want yen filterberg to extend
yet again into 2024 and then next year
for allies to decide who will be the
next Secretary General but frankly this
one last thing it is quite strange that
it's taken all this time and they still
all the Allies still haven't managed to
decide who is going to lead them at this
crucial time with war in Europe but it's
definitely not going to be Britain's
defense secretary
really interesting uh Deborah a quick
thought from you as well about you know
how much of a disappointment do you
think this will be for the UK and for
Ben Wallace
but if that's going to be a big
disappointment I think
um I mean but they've people have made
no secret it's that the process of being
Secretary General the candidates usually
keep it quite quite quite tight
um in terms of whether they're running
or not not coming out until they know
for sure they've got the job because
it's all done behind closed doors and
allies agree it has to be consensus
um but Ben Wallace hasn't denied the
rumors that have been going around that
he is in the running for this job if it
is true that Rishi sunak did Lobby uh
the president of the United States on
behalf of Ben Wallace then if it is also
true that the US has said no to that it
is a bit of a snub for the UK as well
really interesting uh Deborah thank you
very much for talking us through at that
breaking story this evening
well that's it for the take we will be
back next week and every week on
Wednesday at 9 00 PM lots to discuss
with the economy tonight's next up
though it is Sky News at 10. thanks for
watching
[Music]
foreign